ich sage ihnen was mir jetzt so gemacht
und darüber müssen wir in den nächsten
tagen sehr schnell sprechen
das ist die entwicklung im augenblick
3500 fälle mehr als vor einer woche ich
weiß dass wir bundesländer haben die
sachsen thüringen brandenburg sachsen
anhalt in denen wären ziemlich freien
anstieg der zähler
aber selbst wenn wir die rausrechnen
haben wir immer noch anstiege und bis
weihnachten sind es noch 14 tage genau
14 tagen
und wir müssen alles tun dass wir nicht
wieder ein exponentielles wachstum und
hat uns die leopoldina für diese zeit
gesagt wir sollen alle kontakte die
nicht absolut notwendig sind wirklich
reduzieren und mein und so hart das ist
und ich weiß wie viel liebe dahinter
steckt wenn bücher in stände aufgebaut
werden denn waffelbäckerei aufgebaut
werden es verträgt sich nicht mit der
mit dem vereinbarung dass wir zum
beispiel essen und verzehren nur zum
mitnehmen nach hause wirklich
vereinbarung
es tut mir leid aber es ist mir wirklich
im herzen leid aber wenn wir dafür den
preis zahlen dass wir todeszahlen von
tag am tag 590 menschen haben dann ist
das nicht akzeptabel aus meiner sicht
und deshalb müssen wir
und wenn sie wissen
geradezu alfred vor weihnachten bevor
man oma und opa großeltern und ältere
menschen sieht eine woche der kontakt
reduzierung zu ermöglichen
dann sollten wir vielleicht doch noch
mal nachdenken ob er nicht irgendeinen
weg finden die ferien nicht erst am 19
beginnt zu lassen sondern vielleicht
schon am 16 was wird man dann im
rückblick auf eine jahrhunderte eigenes
mal sagen wenn wir nicht in der lage
waren für diese drei tage noch
irgendeine lösung zu sehen und das mag
ja sein
es mag ja sein dass die aufhebung der
schließlich das falsche ist dann muss es
der digital unterricht oder sonstwas
sein
ich weiß es nicht das ist auch nicht
meine kompetenz da würde ich mich die
heimischen ich will über sagen denn der
jetzt vor weihnachten zu viele kontakte
ab und anschließend es das letzte
weihnachten mit den großeltern war dann
werden wir etwas versäumt haben das
sollten wir einen stuhl und die
leopoldina hat auch recht wenn sie uns
mahnt dann nach der zeit des zurück fans
die möglichst höchste berechenbarkeit
für die weiteren maßnahmen dann auch
aufzuzeigen ich meine wenn wir ganz
realistisch sind dann müssen die
winterzeit geht bis mitte märz
das ist eine überschaubare zeit von
anfang januar bis mitte märz die kriegen
wir werden dann nach menschlichem
ermessen einen impfstoff haben dann wird
sich das von monat zu monat verbessern
und wir müssen jetzt uns noch einmal
anstrengen die haben es schon so viele
monate mit diesem virus verbracht und
wir haben doch gelernt wir können etwas
dagegen tun das ist ein bisschen
unmenschlich dass ich immer auf distanz
gehen muss dass ich kein treffen soll
und wenn dann nur mit
schutzvorrichtungen das ist richtig und
diesen monats
aber das ist ja auch nicht etwas was
unser leben für total zerstört
und deshalb sollten wir schauen dass wir
nicht zu viele menschenleben zerstören
und gleichzeitig das wissen der damit
auch die wirtschaft am laufen halten und
in diesem sinne bitte ich sie auch die
nächsten nicht einfachen tage mit uns
gemeinsam durchzustehen herzlichen dank
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren